OKAY GOOD MORNING AND WELCOME
TO THE MARCH EIGHTEENTH
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE HEARING THE I'D LIKE
TO WELCOME OUR NEW COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVIES
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVINE.
GOOD HE IS HERE IN FOR CHAIRED
LIKE TO THINK OR SUBSTITUTE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MARC BERMAN- IS SEVEN
AND FOR MR QUIRK. AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER- MCCARTY AND THREE OF US
WHO ARE COVERING COMMITTEE
VACANCIES THANK YOU. WE HAVE
ONE BILL TODAY SB FIFTY ONE BY
CENTER DRAWS SO TO CONSIDER
THIS MORNING. BEFORE WE BEGIN I
HAVE A FEW HOUSEKEEPING NOTES
TO COVER WE ARE KEEPING A
PHYSICAL DISTANCE BETWEEN ONE
ANOTHER IN A HEARING ROOM
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL BUILDING.
WE'RE ABLE TO HAVE A NUMBER
LIVE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WATCHING
PARTICIPATING HERE IN PERSON I
ACTUALLY DON'T SEE THAT ANYONE
IS HERE. WE'RE ALSO REQUIRING
THAT MASS BE WORN AT ALL TIMES
WE ACCEPT PUBLIC COMMENT BEFORE
THE CLOSE OF THE HEARING. THE
CALL IN LINE FOR TESTIMONY
TODAY IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX
NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN.
IN THE ACCESS CODE IS. TWO FOUR
TWO SIX TWO THREE SEVEN.
PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATED
PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE AT. 916-319-2081 AND
MY STAFF WILL TRY TO HELP YOU.
I ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT WE
ACCEPT WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH THE COMMITTEES EMAIL
SYSTEM AND THROUGH THE POSTAL
SERVICE IS DESCRIBED IN
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. THANK YOU FOR BEARING
WITH US- AS WE IMPLEMENT
METHODS TO CONTINUE TO KEEP US
ALL SAFE. I HAVE NO IDEA IF WE
HAVE A QUORUM KIND OF LOOKS
LIKE THAT WE DO CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. GONZALEZ HASN'T
BIGELOW. BONTA. CALDERON KERIO.
CHAO. GOOD DOLLING. DAVIES FALL
GABRIEL GARCIA. LEVINE BERMAN.
ROBERT RIVAS MCCARTY AND
THREE OF US. BROWSE FULL HOUSE
ALL RIGHT WE'RE ALL HERE AND
WITH THAT. ANY COMMENTS TO MY
VOICE HEARD. ALL RIGHT WITH
THAT WE WILL BEGIN WITH SB
FIFTY ONE BY CENTER DID ALSO IT
ENJOYS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
I HAVE A MOTION FROM MISS
CARILLO AND A SECOND FROM MISS
DAVIES GO AHEAD MISS. OUR
MISTER US THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND FOR SOME TO THANK GOD- MY
COLLEAGUES MEMBER BUT WE- FOR
ALL OR ENORMOUS A- HELPING ON
THIS AND COFFEE NINE THIS BILL-
THE BILL IS VERY POOR TO OUR
COMMUNITY. AND WE'RE GOING TO
PER ME COST SAVINGS FOR THE
STATE IT'S A MODEL FOR
PRODUCING MORE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND ENHANCING AND
BUILDING WEALTH THROUGH
HOMEOWNERSHIP. AND SB FIFTY ONE
ALIGNS WITH- GOVERNOR NUISANCE
EXECUTIVE ACTIONS TO FOSTER
HOUSING INNOVATION ON EXCESS
STATE LAND AND RAPIDLY INCREASE
THE HOUSING OPTIONS. SO IT'S A
PROVIDES A PATHWAY TO
HOMEOWNERSHIP BUT IT ALLOWS FOR
THE SALE OF CALTRANS PROPERTIES
TO QUALIFIED HOUSING RELATED
ENTITIES SUCH AS AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. AND NONPROFIT
HOUSING ENTITIES AT THE
CALTRANS ORIGINAL PRICE
PURCHASE. IN EXCHANGE FOR A
GUARANTEE A PROVIDING FIFTY
FIVE YEARS OF AFFORDABLE AND
MODERATE INCOME HOUSING. AN HR
WE WILL BE ABLE TO BUY THE
PROPERTY AT THE ORIGINAL PRICE
BUT IN EXCHANGE FOR REMODELING
PRESERVING AFFORDABILITY AND
MAINTAINING THEM. OVER FIFTY
YEARS CALTRANS BOUGHT HNDREDS
OF PROPERTIES ALONG THE SEVEN
TEN CORRIDOR. IN THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES- PASADENA SOUTH
PASADENA- THEY WERE PREPARING
TO BUILD A FREEWAY. IN JANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY THE LEGISLATURE
DECLARED THERE WOULD BE NO FREE
BABY BUILT THROUGH THESE CITIES
SB FIFTY ONE ONLY APPLIES TO
THE PROPERTIES WHICH ARE THE
MAJORITY IN THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES DUE TO THIS OPPORTUNITY
NEARLY ONE HUNDRED HOMES ARE
CURRENTLY UNOCCUPIED. MANY ARE
IN POOR CONDITION WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REPAIR AND
IMPROVE THE HOUSING IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD AT NO COST TO THE
STATE AND TO INCREASE LONG TERM
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
CALIFORNIA. IT IS ALSO FISCALLY
PRUDENT RIGHT NOW CALTRANS IS
REQUIRED TO FIX THE HOMES IN
ORDER TO SELL THE PROPERTIES.
AS MOST OF THESE HOMES WOULD
NOT QUALIFY FOR HABITABILITY
STANDARDS CALTRANS IS ALSO
INCURRING SIGNIFICANT COSTS. TO
PREVENT HOMES FROM BEING
OCCUPIED WITHOUT PERMISSION. SO
COLLEAGUES THIS BILL MOVES US
SIX TO MOVE OWNERSHIP AWAY FROM
CALTRANS. INTO THE HANDS OF
INDIVIDUAL OWNERS SECURE
AFFORDABILITY AND INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF AFFORDABLE UNITS AND
PROTECT CURRENT ALL CALTRANS
TENANTS. LASTLY IF VACANT
PROPERTIES WERE TO GO THROUGH
EXISTING RULES THEY WOULD BE
OPTIONED UP. OFF OPEN TO THE
HIGHEST BIDDER AND THAT WOULD
BE A RECENT RECIPE FOR
DISPLACEMENT AND GENTRIFICATION.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR UNABLE
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU.
THAT HAS A MOTION AND A SECOND
AND SO WE WILL GO TO COMMENTS
FROM- COMMENTS AND SUPPORT IS
THERE ANYONE WHO'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT IS THERE
ANYONE HERE IN THE GALLERY I
SEE NONE. I SEE NONE- IS AT&T
ON THE LINE IS THERE ANYBODY
CALLING IN IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB FIFTY ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE TWO ZERO. AND
THE OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU
WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER AND PLACE
YOU BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB FIFTY ONE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN THERE- NOW. MADAM CHAIR
LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE ABOUT SEVEN
EIGHT PARTICIPANT IN Q. OKAY GO
AHEAD. WHY NUMBER TWENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BY NUMBER TWENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN MAYBE ON MUTE.
LINE NUMBER TWENTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MANAGER
MEMBERS AGAIN- HANDS WEEK HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES
MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI WE
APPRECIATE CENTER ALSO TAKING
QUICK ACTION- LUCAS BUT
INSPIRATION TO STRIKE A VERY
IMPORTANT BALANCE BETWEEN
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF VERY RARE
RESOURCES. OR HORRIBLE HOUSING
WHILE STILL PRESERVING THE
RIGHTS OF THE TENANTS TO BE IN
A POSITION FOR OWNERSHIP AND
ALSO MAKING SURE THAT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE MULTIPLE
BALLOTS WILL BE FLOWN
AFFORDABLE ABBY PRIORITIZE
GOING FORWARD FOR THESE REASONS-
THERE ARE THREE TO FOUR. THANK
YOU AT THIS WILL TAKE MY NUMBER.
JUST PEOPLE'S NAME IN ORDER.
AND POSITION AND SOME. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR LINE NUMBER
TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU- MY
NAME IS C. MARKRAM STIR I THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF EARNS
EDUCATORS TEACHERS AND STUDENTS
INACTION I WRITTEN A LETTER IN
SUPPORT- BEING THAT WE PROVIDE
A LOT OF SERVICES TO- FAMILIES
IN THIS AREA ESPECIALLY YOUTH-
EDUCATIONAL MENTAL HEALTH
SUPPORT. AND IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT- TO ALLOW THEM- THIS
OPPORTUNITY MY LETTER GOES INTO
DETAIL BUT WHAT I WANT TO THANK
YOU STATE THANK YOU WHAT IS
IMPORTANT FOR OUR BERMAN IS TO
LEARN. FROM THE SOUND- WE'RE
JUST P. NAME AND THERE ARE. AND
THEIR PER AT THIS POINT SO
THANK YOU. MY NUMBER TWENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS ANDREA
LOPEZ AND I AND THEN ALSO YOU
KNOW RESIDENT AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB FIFTY ONE THANK YOU.
BY NUMBER TWENTY THREE THE LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS ANTHONY
HERNANDEZ- I'M A RESIDENT I
KNOW I NEED TO FOR OF THAT THE
FIFTY ONE POINT FOR THE HOME
THANK YOU. LINE NUMBER EIGHTEEN
YOUR LINE AT OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS MARIA
MARTINEZ AND I AM A RESIDENT
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT AT THE
FIFTY ONE. THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MORNING MY NAME IS A
TWENTY GARCIA I LIVE IN AT THAT
I KNOW AND I SUPPORTED THE
FIFTY ONE. I THANK HIM. MY
NUMBER ELEVEN YOU LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS MARIE SALAS AM MAKE. TENANT
HERE IN ITS CITY NOW I SUPPORT
SB FIFTY ONE THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS MONICA LOPEZ
AND I'M ACCOUNT NO RECORD AND I
STE SUPPORT SB FIFTY ONE. THANK
YOU. I NUMBER THIRTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS MONICA
VARGAS I AM INTERESTED IN A
RESIDENT AND I SUPPORT AT THE
FIFTY ONE. THANK YOU. HI MADAM
CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE CAN
QUEUE THANK YOU SO MUCH AT THIS
TIME WILL MOVE TO OPPOSITION I
THINK THERE IS. PRESENTATION OF
OPPOSITION THAT CAN GO FOR TWO
MINUTES FOR BIRD OF FLOORS WITH
UNITED CALTRANS TENANTS I THINK
IS IN OPPOSITION AND HE WILL-
SPEAK FOR NO MORE THAN TWO
MINUTES ON THE FISCAL ISSUES
INVOLVED. IF HE'S THERE. THAT
WOULD BE HEY HE'S NOT ON WEBEX
WE'LL GO HEAD TO MOVE TO THE
PHONE LINES- IF HE'S ON THE
PHONE LINES WERE BIRDO CAN
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OTHERWISE
WE'RE JUST TAKING PEOPLE'S NAME
AN ORGANIZATION AND POSITION IN
OPPOSITION TO SB. FIFTY ONE.
THANK YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FIFTY ONE.
PRESS ONE ZERO. AND THE
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOUR LINE
NUMBER IN PLACE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. SB FIFTY
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO NOW.
A REPORT- IF YOU'RE ON THE LINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO NOW AS
WELL. SHE'S THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIRWOMAN. IT LOOKS LIKE WE
HAVE SEVEN IN Q. LINE NUMBER
TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
FOUR MAIN AN ORGANIZATION
PLEASE GO AHEAD. APOLOGIES
LIBBY PHANTASM BEHALF OF AT THE
ARE OU CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
NOT OPPOSITION. ONE OF THE-
SHE'S GOT. I NUMBER THIRTY YEAH
LINE OF THE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI- MY NAME IS MATTHEW DOT. I
WOULD BE ELSE ONE TWO THAT
TRUST IN I AGAINST THIS THE
STUDENT. AND BATTLE WRITTEN BY.
IT I THINK. THE LINE NUMBER
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
CALL. HI MY NAME DON FERNANDEZ
I'M A LONG RIGHT OF THE AUTHOR
AND ALL AND I SUPPORTS IN TO US
LOOK AT SPEECH. ONE THANK.
FINAL THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
ALL PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THERE
AMONG TIME COMMUNITY ACTIVIST
OF IT SAID. DEALING WITH
AFFORDABLE AND WE ARE AND I
UPHOLD. BOB AT THE PRETTY WOMAN
IS ABOUT THE THINGS THANK YOU.
MY NUMBER TWO FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. BERMAN
VOTER UNIFORM BEARD NAKED UNDER
THE TO THE CONFIRM ACOSTA
CANNOT IS A- LISTED PUTS YOU IN
AS. THANK YOU LINE NUMBER
THIRTY FIVE ONE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
THE LAND THAT YET ORGANIZER IN
SUPPORT OF THE UC CALTRANS
CANON. AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE SB
FIFTY ONE. THANK YOUNG. THANK
YOU TOM ADAMS HERE WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN Q. OKAY- WE WERE
HOLDING THAT SPOT FOR ROBERTO
FLORES TO SPEAK AGAINST IT BUT
SINCE HE IS NOT HERE WE HAVE
CONCLUDED- THE TESTIMONY FOR
AND OPPOSE DEPART DO WE HAVE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NOPE ALL
RIGHT. NOT HERE THIS IS UNUSUAL
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS I SEE
NO QUESTIONS THERE IS A
BIPARTISAN MOTION AND SECOND-
WOULD YOU LIKE US TO VOTE NOW
SENATOR JOHNSON YES PLEASE
MANAGER THANK YOU THAT GETS OUT
ON A ROLL CALL THANK YOU THE
STRESS OF AND THAT CONCLUDES I
DID WANT TO POINT OUT TO AYE I
LEFT OUT. IT'S CALDERON AS A
NEW MEMBER- IT REPLACING THE
OLD CALDERON AS A MEMBER OF
THIS COMMITTEE BUT I THAT'S WHY
WHY IT ESCAPED US BUT I'M WITH
THAT THANK YOU ALL. FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND WE ARE DONE.